Wendy starts off this hour in Washington
hi Wendy how are you hi Dave hi Christie
how are you guys great thumbwheel
i am finding myself in a predicament
these days I am 46 and getting a divorce
and with the pandemic going on right now
the courts are not having any trials or
any hearings and so we've been split
since August and we're not able to
finish proceeding with the divorce so
that part of it put me is very
financially strapped with just now going
down to my income and having to pay rent
so I'm not sure what to do and how long
this pandemic is going to happen because
when we're all finished you know he's
sitting in the house right now that we
have a hundred thousand of an equity
loan taken out and then the house will
about 2:30 on it now my name is not on
the house loan of 230 it's only on the
equity loan and I need to sell it
because I'm gonna need that equity out
of that house in order to get out of
debt and get into another home so I
guess my question is where should I go
from here I took out these 16 thousand
dollar loan from my 401k so I'm paying
myself back the interest five of it has
gone so far for my attorney's fees and
the the remaining ten thousand is just
sitting there right now with me trying
to figure out exactly where I should go
from here okay so what do you make I
make sixty four thousand a year you shut
up your budget to live on that what's
that have you set up your budget to live
on that I have but I have to in order
for me to be able to do that I'm gonna
have to pay off some debt in order to I
have about twenty one thousand and
credit-card debt a car if that's all in
my name yeah we kept our financial parts
separate we each had a portion that we
paid and contributed to the marriage I
have a car and that's what really kills
me is I still twenty five thousand on it
it's $40,000 car okay yeah you know
twenty-five all right what's it worth
today
what's it work today probably only
twenty eight thousand won't you sell it
I you know I think I should but the
thing is we're still in the middle of
Orson we're still dividing the equity
and that's what I'm afraid of
you know if I get rid of this is he
gonna have more stake inequities than me
well so so the divorce there's no
settlement on the divorce you're gonna
have to go before the judge to get a
settlement correct because he believes
that I should not be entitled to any
equity in the house actually okay have
you asked your attorney what would it do
to you if you sold your car I have not
done that yet call him right now okay I
will definitely a $25,000 $28,000 car
does not fit in a sixty four thousand
dollar budget no so it needs to go and
you were gonna pay it off I don't want
you pay it off I want you get rid of it
I want you get a ten thousand dollar car
right that you can own free and clear or
less and get your life on balance
without him are you anticipating support
from him as well other children involved
no children in fact we had a zoom
hearing for temporary for him to remain
in the house and he actually tried to
get it spousal support from me and the
judge said no okay so he's a real
gamesman
he is this mother is physically he can
do no wrong and she just gives them
anything he wants he can't afford to
live in that house but she's supporting
it okay well I don't really care about
her I'm just trying to help you right so
I think
yeah I think you get your life on
balance here's the thing when you're
dealing a guy like that I think you can
starve him out if you can get yourself
in a position that you can float right
right now you're the one that's
motivated by this weight I'd rather let
this weight way on him he's the one with
the big payment over there
well he's his payments actually less
than my Renta's and I am a type of
person who's always owned since I was 18
this is the longest I've ever rented in
my life and you're not dying you're not
dying from Rennie no you've got you've
got to get through this thing and it's
not going to happen anytime soon so you
got to get yourself stabilized because
the divorce isn't going to be final it's
a contested divorce and you've got to
get before the judge to get it settled
and it's going to be a little while or
in your state in particular your state's
one of the slower ones to open and get
back to work if you're in Tennessee you
probably be before the judge by now so
this is the impact of the continued
coronavirus shutdown on stuff like this
but plus you're dealing with the
heartbreak of the situation yeah it's
very hard yeah I would revisit the
budget as well Wendy because when you
said yes when Dave asked you if you
could live on that amount of income you
said yes if I get rid of this debt and
that's going to take some work and it's
going to take money to be able to do
that so I would just say even especially
if you're able to if you are able to
sell the car that margin from that car
payment figuring out how you can live on
that budget realistically making sure
that budget works because you know it's
real tempting to create a budget that's
a pie in the sky but you're in a tough
season and put a really honest lens on
this budget to make sure you're going to
be okay because that's gonna be really
stressful if you set yourself up to fail
because it's a budget that's not
realistic so I would say we look at that
especially with the car payment gone
agreed